ciao questo è un microscopico video per
ringraziarvi di questo 2016 fantastico
quest'anno è stato il cambio del canale
all'hate show con karim usa e devo dire
che a parte una partenza un pochino
magari lenta perché si doveva assestare
il genere
devo dire che sono piuttosto soddisfatto
di quello che è uscito fuori l'anno
prossimo mi piacerebbe ampliare ancora
di più i tipi di contenuti farli più
vari
magari riuscì a riuscire si spera a
invitare gente diversa fare video
insieme a me più sketch più corto metà
non lo so non lo so vedremo ea tutto
questo io ci ho pensato
dopo quello che è successo giorni fa
all'inizio di dicembre in un centro
commerciale praticamente stava
aspettando martina fuori da kiko sembra
quasi uno sketch di pintus però è nata e
succede per davvero sarà stavo
aspettando
e noto che un ragazzo mentre mi passa
davanti o era appoggiato a una pensilina
mi passò davanti un ragazzo e mi dice oh
ma tu sei mio tobin si stia già
guardando bene tutto bene grazie
complimenti come le solite cose e mi
dice se ti possiamo fare una foto dico
certo come no però non sono bravo coi
self io non riesco a farli di solito c'è
gente che ha problemi a farsi selphy
perché viene male quindi non riesce a
farli oppure non riesce col pollice ad
arrivare fisicamente a farsi un self e
quindi di solito si chiede aiuto
qualcuno li vicino e vicino a me c'era
un altro signore che stava aspettando la
moglie sempre da kiko
e allora recano scusi vi può farci una
foto e ci fa la fotografia ci
abbracciamo si fa la fotografia arida il
cellulare al proprietario è un ragazzo
ci sopportiamo grazie mille complimenti
grazie a te grazie che non c'erano cosa
ciociara e pavia e il signore che ha
fatto la foto a fianco a me si appoggia
dimora pensieri mi guarda colpito
proprio indicati c'è ma scusa non
eravate amici e io in imbarazzo perché
sapevo dove stava per andare a parare la
conversazione nessuno col cellulare dico
no no no e continuo a guardare noi
sembra candidato dice ma ma ma allora
perché chi ha chiesto una fotografia e
io che sapevo dove stavo per andare la
conversazione per non iniziare a dove
gli spiegare youtube dove ti posso
provare con che nome ti posso trovare
suite restare lì in mezzo alla gente a
dire sta roba
ho detto guardandolo è no è
semplicemente apre segno i lavori e sono
tornando amore da portata onestamente
guarda male poi si allontana dicendo è
ok vole feste e glielo guardato andare
via franto buone feste
questa scene perché è capitato
all'inizio di dicembre in questo centro
commerciale
mi ha fatto pensare perché la domanda
del signore era legittima perché lui che
ha chiesto una fotografia sembri tuo
amico e questo mi ha fatto pensare mi ha
fatto auto analizzare nella situazione
in cui sono adesso c'è una persona un
signor nessuno una persona qualunque a
cui la gente chiede delle fotografie e
continua ad arrivarmi sempre lo stesso
pensiero cioè che se io non avessi avuto
youtube sarei probabilmente in mezzo a
una strada perché mi sono diplomato e
poi ho smesso gli ho fatto un anno di
università
ho visto che studiare non era per me e
quindi ho detto lasciamo perdere poi
ringraziato gli è arrivato un lavoro che
mi ha permesso di mettere via i soldi
per tre anni e poi ho deciso di fare
youtube a tempo pieno e voi ridete
perché a tempo pieno vuol dire che devi
fare video tipo sempre invece io ne
faccio di meno delle persone normali che
lavorano con youtube perché e poi inizio
a pensare al futuro perché questa anche
quest'anno è finito in fretta io non mi
ricordo neanche cosa ho fatto a san ad
agosto settembre ottobre talmente
passato in fretta e quindi per il futuro
è questo che forse forse potrebbe finire
tutto questa cosa qua che youtube non è
una cosa che può andare avanti
all'infinito e impossibile poter portare
avanti all'infinito
io non posso arrivare a 43 anni a fare
video io mi devo trovare qualcos'altro
da fare e non sono arrivati gli
spettacoli e gli spettacoli questa
nostra andati alla grande è stato è
l'esperienza più bella della mia vita a
fare gli spettacoli comicità dal vivo di
stand up
poi però arriva sempre quel pensiero
quel paese lì ti trafigge lateralmente
il cervello perché lo sai che fai
soltanto il comico non ti fa mangiare e
il tu magari vuoi lasciare youtube e
vuoi fare il comico di professione ma
per fare il comico di professione
ieri per forza fare un programma
televisivo anche devi magari l'affare la
comparsata al cinema di fare l'attore
comico e quindi lavorare anche di film
degli altri o devi farli interviste
pagate magari si chiama l'adulto perché
la tua carriera è finita e quindi ti
devi far pagare quelli 10.000 15.000
euro per un'intervista
e come cazzo faccio a passare un felice
anno nuovo con tutti sti cazzo di
pensieri per la testa e hanno voluto
dare questo turista del leccio però per
il me per fare ciò bisogna partire da
zero quindi ti guardi in giro proprio
vedere cosa fa il resto del mondo il
resto dell'italia per quanto riguarda la
comicità e che cazzo vuoi che faccia il
resto del mondo per quanto riguarda la
comicità mm ma solo quello he man
adesso siete riusciti a portare in auge
alberto angela e magalli senza motivo
questo e la comicità che tutti
condividono magalli alberto aggio ma
magari alberto angela magalli faceva
piazza grande quando io ero piccolo e
nessuno la vedeva adesso tutti a mano
magari ma nessuno quando a piazza grande
ma allora perché cazzo vediamo vedere
magari intervistato dei programmi dove
magari non dovrebbe mai può esserci ma
lo imitano soltanto perché adesso è
diventato famoso su internet i nem
alberto angela c'era quando ero piccolo
e enrico papi ma perché io mi devo
vedere enrico papi non vi do di roma si
solo perché è diventato famoso su
internet che poi perché non fate
diventare mamme e fate invitare le
persone che hanno problemi
fa bene da baby claudio lippi che ha
appena detto che a meno di 7.000 euro
nel conto ma fate diventare lui bene
fate andare lui nel momento di roma xvi
omar con coloro che ci ha avuto 17 ictus
e fa le pubblicità con le transizioni
del cazzo orribili che chiunque si
assumano un meme di per sé ma che
nessuno ha fatto diventare meme e tv
voglia di mandare a [ __ ] a voi ea
tutta la vostra famiglia
questo è un video di merda era noioso
era fastidioso e anche un po
qualunquista ma lo possiamo sistemare
ciao vuole feste felice anno nuovo a voi
a tutta la vostra famiglia a posto
[Musica]
no